airless pumps are kind of a lie standard
airless pumps have a hole going from the
outside world into the product open the
whole time and yes oxygen can
potentially go through the rubber tee
but that is going to be a lot harder
than just going through the big hole in
the Airless pump or even through all the
gaps in the mechanism that's why in a
proper chemistry lab with lots more air
sensitive substances than skincare you
just do not find airless pumps a two
component screwtop container has a lot
less potential leakages than a complex
multi-component Airless pump which has
lots of hard surfaces touching against
each other and not forming a great seal
airless pumps are still great that
reduced heads space can help keep out
microbes especially if the product is a
bit thicker and they are really
convenient you can pump them out at lots
of different angles and clumsy people
like me can drop them and it's usually
fine unlike with a dropper some pumps do
have fancier mechanisms that are better
at keeping out oxygen but the dropper
bottle is really underrated for oxygen
sensitive products there was a study on
the stability of lots of different rol
products and one of the most stable was
in a Dro a bottle